[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is Gungan here welcome to the
twelfth episode of dirty chess tricks
against sicilian in this episode I'm
going to show you some wonderful tricks
in the Sicilian especially co-main line
from the white respective the opening
arises after the falling water
efore c5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d4c
captures d4 Knight captures d4 Knight to
f6 attacking on e4 Knight to c3
defending and now this time attic trusts
in the center ePHI ok the main line
continues with Knight to be 5 so looking
at the d6 square so blacks top this with
d6 and now comes Bishop to g5 pinning
down the f6 Knight ok
black plays a 6 kicking the knight
Knight to b3 and now b5 and simple
intention is to grab the piece with
before so white response is force white
has to first take on f6 now here if
Queen takes the knight to defy it comes
with a tempo so the usual response is G
captures f6 and now comes Knight to defy
anyways here it doesn't matter whether
your opponent continued with Bishop to
g7 or fi this both main line leads to
the same part let's say Bishop to g7 C 3
so white is trying to cement his defy
control but black has more than happy as
he has this attacking stuff going on on
the Kings side with the MU half are
trying to destroy white center ok
white place he captures fi Bishop
captures fi night to c2 castle on the
King side and now come the thematic move
my to e3 attacking bishop black needs to
control D Phi square so he played Bishop
to e6 white continue with his King side
pissed
with Bishop to d3 and here comes the
vital attacking scheme by a black that
is Fi and you can see that is e for or F
for looming in there and that is the
reason why this Resnik o is a choice of
many attacking Sicilian player at this
position I am going to recommend a very
cunning move castle on the Kings side
and the trick is set right here now as I
have highlighted over here black has
plenty of choice and amongst them rook
to e7 is probably the main line but has
happened frequently an unexperienced
Reznick o player is going to churn out
either of this three moon that is f4 e
for or Knight to e7 where white obtained
a great advantage with some dirty chest
tricks in hand so let's see each bite on
the first move I want to consider is
Knight to e7 which looks very obvious
black is trying to get rid of the defy
pesky night but the sad news is after
this move white is completely winning
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a move which
gives Y a very good advantage
did you spot it have you find out this
sequence that is night captures Esau in
Czech Queen to e7
and now the decisive blow ah ah ha ha so
suddenly from nowhere white is a clear
pawn up and the tactical point behind it
is
if black tried to capture on f5 let's
say Bishop captures f-fire Knight
captures fi and rook captures a fire
then there comes when to defy King to
etch a and just within 20 moves on the
game white emerged with exchange and
upon up but a completely winning
position so even though Knight is seven
looks so good and played in hundred and
fifteen games so far in the field to na
means it is a big time mistake from the
black same goes for the second move f4
which at first sight looks so Gould and
many / Nico inexperienced player are
going to play this but the problem here
is what has this little moon went to h5
attacking one at 7 and if the move at
6:00 then Queen to g6 is a very strong
reply so accordingly the only defensive
resource here is rook to f7 giving king
escape square but what is going to give
this check anyways that is Queen check
King to f8 and now comes the star mu
push up to g6
amazingly enough the only sane resource
from the black is to play rook a to e7
but let me ask you this question how
many of your opponent are going to find
this move anyways I have attached a
detailed PG and of that move in the
description so kindly check it out but
many of you will ask the question well
what happens if black can take this
night after all he get to piece for a
rope right well no it's wrong because
after Bishop captures Bishop captures
and now F captures III yes black has to
bishop against rook which is generally a
strong idea but not in this position
because black King is in a great danger
white queen is very nicely placed and on
top of everything white has this to
distant passer which more than enough to
convert into the winning advantage well
one more thing what happens if black
tried to go away with the rook let's say
rook F to e7 well here in fact what has
a strong move he does not need to move
the knight and instead of that he can
continue with Queen to h5 obviously
black cannot take this night because of
F captures III and in order to save the
maid black has to give up the Queen
which is a vast news for the black so
that's not even a possibility and
instead of that computer suggests the
strong move here is Knight to e7 but
still after this we can continue with
Knight captures a7 Queen captures a
seven and now comes Knight to f5
attacking two sports
so black responses force black has to
capture on a fire but after Bishop
captures fi white emerge with an extra
pawn and black has hardly any
compensation for it
last but not least what happens if you
open and continue here with the movie
phone which in fact played in hundred
and fifty-two games
well this moves not that bad but the
follow-up which most of the black player
has done is quite questionable here
white obviously continued with Knight to
f4 counter attacking the bishop bishop
to f7 and now white simply dropped the
bishop back to the c2 squared and here
comes the problem from the black camp if
you check this position in online
database you will find out that at this
position the most popular choice by the
black is to play Bishop to e5 which in
fact not good in this position because
after the move Bishop to e5
white can continue with Knight F to defy
and the main line goes as follows black
plays Queen to g5 which looks a great
attacking spot but in fact after White's
next reply f4 as the two of the black
pieces are hanging black responds his
force he has to capture with the N
percent and when white recapture with
the Queen you can now see the problem in
the black gam F Phi pawn is a clear-cut
target there are many games continue
from here with attacking the Queen Queen
to f2 and now black simply played the
move f4 in order to safeguard the pawn
but I'm afraid this is not going to help
black at all as White has this little
reply boom
so sacrificing the whole piece and
asking black hey what you are going to
do about it now the first obvious
question need to be asked what happens
if black captured this piece when after
that white response is pretty simple and
very direct yup is Quinn sacrifice
Quinn capture Cepheid rook captures a
fate rook captures a fade and it doesn't
matter whether King goes to g7 or
captured the rook it met with the same
reply that is nigh to e6 regaining the
Queen and after King to e7 and Knight
captures defy after the whole
transaction white come up with an
exchange up so as per the engine base
reply goes as follows black continue its
rook to see it attacking both denied but
here comes the whole point of white
white continue with Knight to e6
attacking to spot Quinn to at 6 Knight
captures her fate pawn captures III and
fortunately for White Queen to a5 a
multi-purpose move saving the knight
attacking on at 7:00 and don't forget
the lose rook in the corner okay black
and try this trick that is Bishop
captures s true
so if white capture the bishop then
white queen will be lost but white is
not obliged to capture it and calmly
play King to h1 and after this white is
completely winning after the base
continuation that is Bishop to g3 Queen
captures at 7 Queen takes and knight
takes after 29 move accuracy wide
emerged with exchange and a winning
advantage
well I hope you enjoy and learn this
informative video on the Sicilian
sveshnikov main line remember that if
you're inexperienced especially Co
opponent played either of this three
wrong move then don't forget to punish
him and get the full point well thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on this video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care